- Hi, everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our Ed Talks
live stream which is,
you could view it as a flavor
of our homeroom live stream.
Before we jump into a
very exciting conversation
with Bob Hughes, who's the
director of K-12 US Education
for the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation.
We're gonna talk about
all things education
with a focus on math and algebra.
I will give my standard
reminders that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation at
khanacademy.org/donate.
Also want to give a special shout out to
several organizations that stepped up
especially during the COVID crisis,
when more folks than ever were
dependent on Khan Academy.
And we were running a larger
deficit than ever (laughs)
because our server costs went up,
and everything else went up.
Special thanks to Bank Of
America, AT&T, Google.Org,
NOVARTIS, Fastly, General Motors
and many of y'all who have
donated at all different levels
to make, to allow us to
support all of you (laughs)
in the best way possible
during the pandemic and beyond.
Also want to give a quick reminder,
that there's a podcast version of this
(giggles) live stream,
"Homeroom with Sal The Podcast",
wherever you get your podcasts.
With that, I am excited
to introduce our guest,
Bob Hughes, director of US K-12 Education
at the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation.
Bob, welcome.
- Sal it's great to be here.
I have to tell you, I talked
to my dad about you last night,
and he said thank him,
I learned calculus on the Academy website.
- Oh, was your dad
learning calculus for fun,
or for pragmatic reasons?
- For fun.
He's 85, so he really enjoyed it
and it actually dipped into
the humanities as well.
So you're a family favorite,
it's great to be here.
- No, that's always
good to hear especially
when people are learning
math for math's sake.
Although, there's no shame in learning it
for pragmatic reasons.
So Bob, we've known
each other for a while,
but I always have fun going
to these conversations
cause we can go deeper
than we normally go.
But I will remind everyone
watching on Facebook and YouTube
if you have any questions
for Bob or myself
about foundations, about
math, about education
about really anything about Bob's life,
feel free to put those
questions in the chat.
We have team members who
will surface it to us,
and I'll try to get to as
many of those questions
as possible.
But Bob and I have to get full disclaimer,
to the Gates Foundation.
I think many folks know,
is one of the largest
funders of Khan Academy.
So I definitely have a bias
going into this interview.
(laughs)
I will just call out.
So Bob,
- We've signed the grant agreements.
- Yeah, I think it said
like no hard questions
in the grant agreement.
In fact, I was like, sure,
I'm gonna ask you a few hard ones.
But maybe a good place to start Bob is,
what does the director of U K-12 education
at the Bill and Melinda
Gates foundation do?
What is your focus?
What do you hope to do in the world?
- So we've been working with Bill
and Melinda for, I've
been working with Bill
and Melinda for five years
to really think about,
how we can take knowledge.
Good research based knowledge and turn it
into practices that can benefit more kids.
And specifically we
shifted our strategy about
five years ago, to really focus
on black and Latino youth and
youth experiencing poverty.
When we looked at the
data, the United State
you may remember in the old
days waiting for Superman
when we were talking a lot about
how the United States
with 15th in the world.
When we looked at that
data and we desegregated
by race, and we consistently
saw that white students were
in the top two or three
nations in the world
on tests like the PISA exam.
And African American and Latino students
were way down at the bottom
of the OECD countries
who were actually taking the exams.
We really thought, just as
a matter or a mathematics,
how are we gonna improve
a US public education?
We really decided to shift our focus
to black and Latino, young people
and students experiencing
poverty of all colors.
And so, we believe that the
strategies we're pursuing
and I can tell you some of
them will help all kids,
but we're really focused on
those target populations.
Things we're doing are
right up your alley.
One of the reasons we support
you Sal, we deeply believe
in curriculum and comprehensive
instructional systems.
The goal being that you give
students opportunities, both
inside the classroom and
outside the classroom.
To master those skills,
that are so essential to adult success.
We put a lot of energy in
building full course curriculum
over the last five years, and
then trying to scale those
with districts and intermediaries
across the country.
A second thing we're really
focused on is teacher prep.
Like we need great teachers.
We're lucky to have so many good ones,
but we need so many more.
We're really hunkered down
on this teacher residency model
where you prepare a teacher,
much like you would
prepare a doctor or a nurse
where you put them in a
high-performing school
and give them real support.
And then a final, big area.
There are a couple of
others, but I'll just
stick with some of the headlines.
Is something we call
Continuous Improvement Networks
For School Improvement.
In 24 cities across the country,
we've been funding
intermediaries to really focus
on one of three big problems,
getting kids on track.
And by the end of eighth grade,
that ninth grade transition year.
Which is so important and predictive
of adult success and
ultimately transitions
between high school and a
post-secondary experience.
Like a two or four year community college.
We're really hunkered down on those.
We've asked groups to come up
with innovative strategies
based on research and data.
They can implement in their communities.
Then we're slowly tracking those
and trying to get good
lessons from the field and
and spread those across the country.
- And what's your sense of
either cynicism or optimism?
when I talked to a lot of few
folks in the education world
which we're both in.
There's people are excited
about certain things,
but they're like, yeah,
decades of smart people
trying really good ideas.
But it seems to not make
there, have been measurable
positive impacts.
But when you look about
the whole arc of things,
peop there's at least not
a feeling that there's
been a dramatic improvement
over the last several decades.
What's your sense if that
is true, what's your sense
of why it's been so difficult
and what gives you hope,
that the next 20 or 30 or
40 years could be different?
- I think we've put some really important
pieces of the puzzle in place,
that will enable us to make real progress
over the next 10 or 15 years.
A concrete example is the
common core standards.
Those were really
powerful and aligning lots
of people along a common
framework, to really
help folks understand what works
and what should be not what works.
But what should it be
mastered by students?
What should they know and be able to do
along a developmental progression?
Now, what we're doing is the
second stage of that work,
which is really thinking about curriculum.
Thinking about SEL, thinking
about all the supports
that need to be in place.
To make the promises, those standards
of reality for young
people in their schools.
So, we're starting to see bright spots
in lots of different areas.
Urban areas frequently are criticized
as being cesspools of
ineffective practice.
But in fact, you see
in places like New York
and even in Los Angeles and a variety
of urban areas, increases in
graduation rates slow increases
in standardized test scores,
slow increases in preparation
for career in college
as measured in New York.
For example, by completion
of the advanced Regents exam,
all of those things are good.
So yes, we haven't had a tidal wave
or a giant transformation.
But I think every single day
we're making small steps that ensure,
that more kids will be
able to complete standards
and go on to a productive life.
I'm super optimistic actually.
And it's just hard work,
education doesn't correct
for a lot of social challenges
but it's absolutely necessary.
We have to invest in that
as we think about ways of
improving social mobility
we're broadly and housing
and income supports
in child support in a
variety of different areas.
- Absolutely.I want to double click
on the common core a little bit
because I'm very familiar
with the history of it
but it has since become somewhat
politicized over the years.
Explain how the common core came about?
I think it's important
for people to realize it,
because there's sometimes this perception
that it's this very much top
down thing that happened.
What was the underlying
narrative behind it?
- I can't give you those specific details,
cause I was busy in schools at the time,
but I was paying attention
to the newspapers
and know a couple of the
actors who were involved.
But really what happened
was States recognized
that they needed fewer
higher and clearer standards.
And so States really started
to lobby to get much more
in the weeds about one
what young people needed to know and do.
And it was really building on
an earlier standards movement
from the eighties and nineties.
But really stripping it down and getting
much more to basics.
The States lobbied and then got
the national governor's association
and a variety of other
groups achieved a push
for these common core
standards more broadly.
They were ratified by individual States.
They definitely were accelerated,
by the us department of education.
You know that the standards
are remarkably enduring.
They become politicized,
but I think 40 to 43 States
I don't have the exact
number have continued
with this idea of standards.
They've modified, they've tinkered them,
they've made them more appropriate
to their local context.
The core of the standards
movement is still there
and it's incredibly powerful.
Even when there's some
tinkering around the edges
and driving better curriculum,
better supplemental support services,
and better assessments for young people.
It's still a little
bit of a lightning rod,
but it's really made a
big difference in quality.
And now we have to push even deeper
and understand what is it
that motivates young people?
How do we create materials
and opportunities
for them to learn and how
do we support teachers
in that really complicated task?
- Absolutely. I always get
this question whenever I speak
at conferences or I speak to the press
and I always say, look it, first of all
the politicization of it
doesn't make sense to me.
This was done as really a governors
to your point like States by state.
They said, it's no pre-Common core.
The big States, New York, California
and Texas had all of the power
because that's where the
publishers would cater to.
Then everyone else would
get some derivative version
of what the publishers were creating
for New York, California, and Texas.
Then we also know that
in any standards creation
everyone kind of wants to throw
in their favorite pet project.
But we realize looking at
countries like Singapore
and Finland, that it's the best practice
and it makes common sense
to focus on fewer things
but do them with real depth.
And I'd also argue that if you
the correlation between
being able to do well
in the common core standards
and any other strong standards,
especially many of them very much derived
from the common core is very high.
It does feel like a little bit of a
a red herring for all
of that focus on that.
What your sense?
You're talking about,
you have the standards
and then the layer above
that is the curriculum,
which is what our students
and teachers doing
on a daily basis.
what are their practice problems?
What does the instruction look like?
How much is it a curricular design issue
versus the implementation
of the curriculum inside of
the classroom, or is it both?
- I think it's really both.
What's exciting about where we've come
in the last five years
is, when the foundation
started doing this work, we
really invested in unit plan.
The ability to create
small units that teachers
would generate,and
implement in their classes.
And that was powerful.
There were a number of good
units that were developed.
But unfortunately it meant that
we were always individualizing the work.
We were always creating
idiosyncratic units,
that couldn't be shared across groups
of teachers to really improve
their practice over time.
Teaching is really
important as an individual
but it's a team sport.
So what we're seeing now is the emergence
of a second generation of curriculum.
Where not only is there a
common scope and sequence,
but there's lots of teacher
choice, and the ability
of teachers work to
working together to judge
whether or not they're having an impact
in particular classrooms
on a daily or weekly basis.
I think that's the big next advance.
You see places like Washington
DC doing their leap program
where they, they adopted
a common curriculum.
It wasn't really just to
shackle teachers and say
you had to teach to the curriculum.
It was actually to give
them a basis to then
modify the curriculum materials
against the needs of
their individual students.
The variation they saw in
their classes, and work
with their colleagues to almost
like Japanese lesson study.
Study the lesson, implement
the study, the lesson
understand which students were successful
in which students failed.
Then come back and re-engineer
that lesson for the next day.
So it's real time improvement.
It's real-time measurement.
It's not a standardized test,
but it's an constant
monitoring of student progress
against the common core
is conceptualization
of what we want students to know
and be able to do.
That really becomes
powerful and really exciting
when you see it well done.
So we're putting our foot on the gas.
We've worked hard to
kind of identify a bunch
of resources that are
aligned to the common core.
And we're now in the process
of going deeper, figuring
out what is effective for
which students when and why.
And use those design principles to push
for a deeper sense of quality
in the curriculum space.
And then your rights Sal,
teachers are crucial.
So really kind of doing embedded
professional development.
So the object of study and
professional development
isn't something abstract
that a supervisor develops.
It's what students are
learning in your classroom.
Why are they learning?
Which students are not learning?
Why are they failing to master a concept?
Really building professional development
that helps teachers solve
those problems in real time.
That's what's job embedded
professional development
is about and that's
what I'm excited about.
We shouldn't forget students
and families in this equation.
And that's where I think
Khan Academy is so crucial.
The fact that young people can kind of go
and get extra help,
follow scope and sequence.
And the Khans platform, is really powerful
and it enables them to do
the deliberative practice
that reinforces the work
they're doing in classes.
I think it's the mixture of what we do
in class and out of class
that can really be powerful,
to driving kids to
higher levels of mastery.
- Yeah. And not just young people.
I've heard, about 85 year
olds learning calculus
on the platform.
- The more the merrier I say
everybody should be on that platform.
- No, that absolutely.
And I know, you mentioned
that you have a renewed
or a double-down focus
on historically
under-resourced populations.
But also there's this focus on math,
and I know in particular algebra one.
What is it about algebra one
that, and you're preaching
to the choir because whatever
you say, I'm gonna double
down (laughs) on why
algebra one is so important.
But in your mind why do you
see that as something of a
of a really important leverage point?
- Well, so I knew intellectually
that algebra one was important.
When you look at the data
it's, a foundational language
and gateway course for
higher STEM classes.
We also know it's one of
the most failed courses
in high school.
Students who don't succeed
in it really struggle
for the remaining three
years that they're there.
In some ways, it's that
pivot point where you're
really not learning you're out
in your mathematics tables,
but you're using a
hundred apply mathematics
to solving problems.
It's that first foray
into abstract reasoning.
And it's so crucial, not only in math
but in a variety of other subjects.
But the funny part to me was I
knew all that intellectually,
but we've started to gravitate towards
some of the math work largely
because that's where
the field wanted to go.
What we started to see was
when we created the networks
for school improvement for example,
there was a real interest in mathematics
as a key subject matter
area to getting young people
on track by the end of eighth grade.
Or it was a subject that
young people were struggling
with in ninth grade.
So we increasingly saw
a significant number
of our grant tees hunkering
down on mathematics.
We also saw the ability to
really build great products
with grantees around
mathematics and get them
out like illustrative map and a variety
of the open educational
resource materials available.
So we gravitated towards math largely
because the field was
gravitating towards math,
I'm glad they are.
So many jobs are related to STEM,
and so much is determined by
whether a young person
can succeed in math.
But I'm super excited about
now is not only thinking
about algebra and all the
math that goes into it,
but the emerging movement
around math pathways.
Really doubling down on
statistics and data science
for young people, which I think
will expand the opportunities
that young people have.
Will make it much more relevant
to the day-to-day life
in courses and in majors.
In college that aren't necessarily related
to statistics, to calculate
thinking algebra and thinking
but really much broader.
So there's lots going on in math,
It's an incredibly exciting field.
I was not particularly
good at math as a kid,
but I'm super excited
about math as an adult.
I, did take a diagnostic,
I still have a little work to
do on my own algebra skills.
- I'm going to start using
the word calculator more.
That's a new word to me, but I'm going to,
and I'll just double down
on what you're saying.
You know, the stats better than I do, 70
I think it's 65, 70% of all, kids who go
to community college in the
US have to take remedial math.
Which is essentially the
community college is saying,
you're not even ready yet
to learn college algebra.
College algebra is essentially,
like algebra one and a half.
It's like someplace in between
algebra one and algebra two.
And we also know that college algebra
is one of these courses
that you have to take.
If you want to pretty much
get a major in anything.
Some people have debated
does it have to be a requirement?
But to your point which I agree with,
I've met employers funders of Khan Academy
who say they divide their employee.
They run restaurants, and
they divide their employees
into those who know algebra.
And those who do not know
algebra, those who are capable
of learning algebra and
the ones that know algebra.
He puts them into the training programs.
They become managers, they
become district managers.
While those who don't
know algebra, they're
they're kind of stuck doing
the non non-managerial
the non career track jobs.
For better, for worse the
world views algebra that way.
And there's probably some good evidence
to your point that it's like
it is how you can show
critical abstract reasoning.
Why do you think so many kids,
algebra is in theory, learned as early
as eighth or ninth grade.
In some places starts
to be learned actually
in the common core starts to be learned
in sixth or seventh grade.
Then kids take other
classes called geometry
and algebra two, and pre-calculus
which is really just more algebra.
Sometimes even take stats or calculus,
and then they go to college
and they're told you're not
ready yet to even learn algebra.
What do you think is going on?
- I think we just need to
rethink how we teach algebra,
and all the mathematics that lead up
to algebra, and then make algebra relevant
to young people in their lives.
So I think it ranges
from the dearth of really
high quality teachers.
We've done a lousy job
preparing math teachers.
We can do a better job,
and we're seeing some
exemplary programs exist
across the country.
I think there are real challenges
in making math relevant.
So we've sometimes adopted
pedagogies that don't necessarily
show why we're learning a
particular math problem,
why it evolved in the history
of mathematics and what
problem it's solving.
I think making it much more relevant just
in its own history is important.
What problems can you solve
in the world using this math?
I remember I've sat in math
classes that were just deadly,
and then I've sat in math
classes that were so exciting
because the teacher was making math real
in the lives of kids
in the lives of communities,
in the lives of workers.
What are you going to need
when you're growing up
and functioning in a job.
what kind of math is going to be essential
to doing that job well?
So I think, there's a whole
pedagogical aspect of math.
And then, the new technologies really
give us opportunities to try to think
about math in different ways.
Some people learn math by visualizing it.
Other people learn math
through multiple ways
of solving a problem to
get to the right answer.
All of those new strategies
and techniques are powerful.
So in a word creating more coherence,
creating greater relevance,
and creating a pedagogy that
enables young people to persist
and succeed over time.
I think if we can really institutionalize
and scale those tools, we're
goinna see a rapid growth
in math over the next five to 10 years.
- And what's your sense of just students
foundational knowledge?
Cause to some degree when they go
to college and the
constantly you're not even
ready to learn algebra yet,
it's almost a side effect of
by-product of year after year.
Maybe the students didn't
have the foundations to go
to the next course, but the
next course was being taught.
And then all of a sudden it gets enforced
at the college level.
Which is you could imagine
an incredibly demoralizing
I've visited middle school classes
that shouldn't be learning algebra.
Where it's clear that a
good number of the kids are,
you ask them eight times seven?
They know what multiplication is,
but they have to recompute it.
They don't immediately
jump to Oh, it's 56.
And then all that computational lounge.
What's the, how do you
think we can address that?
This ability for students to make sure
they have strong foundation.
So that we're building on top of that
as opposed to just promoting
them year after year,
and then they eventually become
part of that 70% statistic.
- It's a great question.
I think one of the challenges
is to understand what greater precision.
What students know and are
don't know in a particular area.
A foundational skills are essential.
But foundational skills
and knowledge are crucial,
and not fluidity in
math as defined by time.
For example, one of the things
I didn't mention, but I think
about a lot because of my
own personal experience
in mathematics is, what turns
the person on to believe
that their math person or
what alienates a person
from being a math person
early on in their lives?
That's true of writing
that you're reading.
But in math in particular,
why is it that so
many young kids, particularly
girls, particularly poor kids
don't think of themselves as math people?
Even though they may have the
native ability to do the work.
In my own experience, I
screwed up and sixth grade,
I was in a parochial
school, I was in math.
I fell behind, I became
embarrassed about that.
I was able to through the intervention
of a really good teacher
who brought me back
at the end of the year.
It didn't make me feel bad,
said we're going to work on this together.
Paste it that individualization
that's so crucial
for many young people in education.
She did that for a number of years
and was able to kind
of really bring me back
in a six month period to
be back on grade level.
I was lucky, I think lots of young people
that I've spoken with, don't have teachers
like that who have the time or resource
and facility, to be able to
give the individualization.
If I hadn't gotten that,
I sure I would have been
alienated from math.
That disenfranchised for math.
Not believing I was good at math
and then slowly getting
alienated and not motivated.
So I think it's foundational skills.
And I think it's the
way we emphasize those
foundational skills to
build Napa identity,
and enthusiasm for math.
It's not only being able to do math,
but I hope we can get to a place
where kids actually enjoy math.
Because it's an incredibly elegant
and beautiful way of
representing the universe.
I once had a math teacher who
said a beautiful problem is
like a beautiful poem.
I don't think can find that far,
I'm much more a poetry person
than a beautiful problem in math person.
But I think there's a real
grain of truth in that.
And the more we can excite
students math in that way,
the more likely we're
able to be, we'll see
gains in student achievement.
- Yeah. Well I agree.
I love poetry too, but
sometimes when you see a
beautiful product in math or a beautiful
it says something very
deep about the universe.
That's whats amazing, the
math that you're doing
is just abstract symbols
but it's representing
a very pure idea that I think sometimes
can give you chills.
I mean I can start kicking
out on all of those things.
There's a lot of talk right now
because of the pandemic learning loss kids
who've been disengaged.
I'm curious about what y'all
have been seeing on that front.
But also in this last a bill
coming through Congress, 120
I think $6 billion is
going down to the States
which will then go to the
districts in the schools.
20% of which has been kind
of tagged for learning loss.
This is a lot of money that is flowing
into the States into school systems.
What's your hopes and fears there?
What do you think this can
be a long-term accelerant?
Cause I don't think there's
ever been an example
of this much money flowing
to schools this quickly.
- Well, just to give you an example
we spend $300 million a year
at the Gates foundation
on public education.
Schools are about to
receive $120 billion a year.
So that really dwarves
everything that's occurring
in philanthropy.
So one of the things we've been working
on is to really try to think
about how to create
coherence and coordination.
So people don't just spend
money on the best idea
that they've thought but
they really are connected
to the research and
thinking hard about what
are the elements that students
need to be successful.
And so over the last few
weeks we've been working
with three really outstanding groups
council of chief state school
officers, chiefs for change
and the council of great city schools.
To really build out a 10 point framework,
key elements that need to be addressed
in any recovery effort.
And then really start to
disseminate that and figure
out what are the best practices,
best organizations and
and tools and resources
that can be implemented
in each one of those areas.
So concretely we know that
much of the learning loss need
for acceleration has been
created by the digital divide.
We still have eight to
12 million students who
don't have regular access
either to equipment
or access to the internet.
We need to solve that problem.
And hopefully 7 billion of
the dollars that are going
through that stimulus
package are designed to go
through the FCC and start to address it.
We're gonna have to continue
to work with districts
and States that both solve
the problem in the short-term
but then in the long-term.
But then, what are the strategies
that are research-based
that can be helpful?
Curriculum is really important.
End of your courses is really
important, opportunities to go
on Khan Academy and do the extra homework
is really important.
But they're also just
individual needs like tutoring.
We've been lucky to work with a variety
of different tutoring groups
that have seen real advances
of acceleration one to two
years in a year of tutoring.
So it'll really be about
identifying those best practices
in coordinating I'm sure like you,
I really have the opportunity to talk
to a lot of superintendents
and chiefs around the country.
It's one of the joys of my job.
And I have to say I've been blown
away by how thoughtful people are.
Absorbing this amount of money in ways
that are, is sustainable over time
and really enables us
to build back better,
but built back braver
is going to be crucial.
And I think in the next
two or three months
we're gonna see some really
interesting plans coming
from a variety of different districts
addressing learning
loss, addressing social
emotional needs, thinking hard
about the digital divide,
thinking hard about,
the host of things that need to happen to
enable our young people
to recover quickly.
- Completely agree.
I've actually just actually
last Friday started
cause cause I talked to so many of these
superintendents of large districts
chief academic officers,
state commissioners
or state superintendents, and they are all
both excited and fearful (laughs)
of what's about to happen.
Because there's a huge
opportunity to do a lot of good
but there's a lot of political pressure
to put the money to work fast
but also not to squander.
Which is reasonable political
pressure on both fronts.
Because of, but I've been very impressed
with how people have
been thinking about it.
How do you ramp into and it's over roughly
the next three, three years or so.
And how do you not make it?
So it's just this blip and
then it doesn't sustain itself.
How do you use these resources
to do real structural change?
And obviously I've had my bigger hat
the Khan Academy hat,
which plays a role where
kids can asynchronously
get practice feedback
and work in a classroom.
And then this new effort
around schoolhouse.
World versus around tutoring,
which is exactly why
this focus on tutoring.
Cause it's great to be able
to go to a Khan Academy,
but unless you have folks
to mentor you, coach you
you have a community to be in.
It's a lot harder for a lot of students
to be able to engage at that level.
So yeah, it's gonna be interesting to
see how all of this evolves.
I want to make sure I get
to questions from folks.
Let's see, I've asked some
of these well, I'll ask one
which is kind of a fun question.
It's a less deep policy question
but I think you have a
unique vantage point.
This is from SmartBear on YouTube.
What does it feel like
working with Bill and Melinda?
What are they like?
- I wonder Bill and Melinda like,
Bill and Melinda are fantastic.
I've been in meetings with
you saw, that Bill is one
of the smartest people
you'll ever deal with.
He really wants to ask the
hard questions, kick the tires.
He has a point of view.
He tells you what that point of view is.
And he really expects
you to tell your point
of view back and not
be intimidated by him.
And we've had just amazing conversations.
I never walk into the room.
I feel like I know a lot about education
but I never walk in the
room, not learning something
from Bill and not learning
something from Melinda.
They're incredibly thoughtful
and incredibly committed to this work.
They've been doing it
now for 23, 24 years.
And they're really in
it for the long haul.
They really want to ensure that,
the foundation's motto
is all have equal value.
They want to make sure
that every young person
has a good education and
can meet their potential.
And it's a real pleasure.
I was trained originally as a lawyer.
So I conceptualize every meeting
with Bill Gates is a little bit
like a Supreme court argument.
You get about five
minutes to state your case
and then you better be
ready for the questions
because they're fast and furious.
But they're always directed
towards the larger purpose
of what we're trying to do.
- Yeah, no, I have to, you
spent more time with them,
but in my interactions, Bill is one
of the few people that in my meeting
he he's able to push
out and he pushes hard
on all the exact right places.
How do we know we're
reaching the right kids?
How do we know we're getting traction?
How do we know we're supporting teachers?
How do we know?
And then like the next meeting
could be with people who are
like working on healthcare
or fighting polio or whatever.
And then he pushes them too
like these are the experts in the field.
So I don't feel as bad.
And not being intimidated by Bill
is easier said than
done, but it's good until
It's easier said than done.
Let's see, in the, I see we're almost
out of time but let's make sure
I have a one more question.
Well, this is a question
from Charles Lamar Dreyden
on Facebook asking, is there, well, I'll
I'll paraphrase the question,
your use on standardized testing.
And the question is
saying measurement tools
showing correlation between
success in standardized testing
but what are your views
on standardized testing?
It's a bit of a hot
topic, but I always say
what part do you disagree,
with the standardized or the testing?
Or is there something
else or how you use it?
How do you do it
- I think tests are important.
I think we need to be innovating
a lot more in this space
to be honest with you.
one thing that's fascinating
is grades are very predictive
of adult success,
extraordinarily predictive.
That may be a matter of statistics.
It's multiple opportunities
to view some young person.
It has SEL and executive
function skills embedded in it.
It can also be very damaging to a student
if it doesn't really include
opportunities to rethink
and redo work.
So I think we need assessments
I think testing is good.
I think part of learning
is having a little anxiety
with what you're learning to retain it
and then ultimately synthesizing it
with other things over
the course of the year.
But we need to make sure
that the tests we give are
are usable for families
usable for students and
and ultimately usable to advance equity.
So I think the, I guess the,
the reality for me is there
four things we ask tests to do
and it may be too many.
We need to start thinking about that.
We need tests to give students
feedback on where they are.
We need tests to give teachers feedback
on where students are and
what they should do next.
We need tests that enable
us to compare schools
and make sure we're living
up to our equity responsibilities.
And ultimately we need
tests to place students
at the next level of education
in ways that are appropriate
with their skills,
interests, and abilities.
So, I think need to do a
lot more in assessment.
And I think that the
foundation we're committed
to innovating around it.
- No, I couldn't couldn't agree more. T
here's nothing wrong with testing
nothing wrong with standardized.
But there's other ways to do it,
because now when you do
work on an online platform,
it is standardized and it
is assessing where you are.
But as continuous, it can be
part of part of the learning.
And also you can make it more actionable.
So it's not, there's ways to do it,
that maybe solve some of the issues.
And then if you make it
actionable where you're
actually able to make
positive constructive actions
based on it then it could be a good thing.
So Bob, I know we're over time
maybe just final thoughts
on anyone listening.
You know, we have parents listening
we have students
listening, we have teachers
what would be the big takeaway
that you would want them to have
for their own lives or
their own children's lives.
And then for the education
system as a whole?
- I think what you're saying, we're coming
off of incredibly complicated
time with the COVID pandemic.
It's going to be super
challenging to address lots
of the problems that young
people have at this moment
but just lean in.
I know teachers are going to be leaning,
in schools are going to be leaning in.
We have resources to be really creative,
and I think it's important to address
but harm students have experienced
over the last year and a half.
But I also think we need
to be a little brave
and think about how can
we transform the system.
So we don't go back to where we were
where we had difficulties
and challenges, but
we build a system that
more effectively addresses
the needs of young people.
That more effectively support students
and are sorry, parents and communities.
In that education process
that uses technology,
and new ways where,
everybody's had an experience
of a virtual platform .
At this point how do we take
what was sometimes ran, tracked
or quickly put together
and actually use it to
drive a better type of
personalization for young people.
So I think it's a time
of incredible promise
if we lean into it, real
challenges as there always are
but real opportunities, if
we're brave enough to seize them
- Right. Well, Bob,
thanks so much chatting
with you.
And obviously we collaborate
on a lot of fronts.
It always leaves me
energized and excited about.
And I agree with you, the future is,
we're at a point where
sometimes it's darkest
before the Dawn, and there's a lot
of really exciting things that
I think will fundamentally
accelerate a lot of folks
learning over the next 10 years.
Thank you so much for joining us.
- Well. Sal thanks for everything you do.
And thanks to the team at
Khan, you guys do amazing work.
We're really proud to sponsor you.
- Thank you so much.
It means a lot to us and
all the people listening
well (laughs)
thanks everyone for joining.
Hopefully you enjoyed that
conversation with Bob.
As much as I did.
I look forward for future
conversations like that and
and please join us at the
next ed talks and or homeroom
with that.
I'll see you, I think I'm
this is the last one for
my week and then I'm going
on vacation.
So it might be a little while
since we see each other but
- Stay tuned.